vous êtes le jardinier en chef du
domaine de Saint-Germain donc grâce à
vous pourrez dans un lieu une personne
de faire d'habitude de Barvaux faire des
jardiniers oui c'est vrai c'est notre
lieu de production pour les plantes là
ici on est au milieu de toutes les
plantes on est en avril au milieu des
plantes qui vont être sur les grands
parters durant cet été tout ça tout ça
produit par les jardiniers uniquement
ailleurs on achète nous on a toujours
décidé parce qu'on fait partie des
métiers d'art du ministère de la Culture
et de la Communication on est décidé de
continuer à préserver nos métiers à
acheter des graines à choisir
spécifiquement nos variétés et donc on
joue sur des teintes des couleurs des
hauteurs et on a un choix exceptionnel
et ça ça va être implanté quand voilà
alors ça va être installé mi-mai pour
être je dirais bien développer
adjoint sur sur le terrain sur les
grands parters face au château
de vos lieux de travail privilégié ici
le cœur de le cœur de métier des
jardiniers à part les arbres là voilà ce
sont les fleurs c'est séduisant pour le
public c'est oui c'est joli là ici voilà
on a on a de la verveine on a de la
patience voyons on essaie aussi de
mélanger un petit peu de légumes d'une
certaine façon donc on a du fenouil ce
qui apporte de la légèreté dans les
floraisons ce qui apporte aussi de la
couleur mais aussi une diversité c'est
bien de montrer aussi au public que d'un
légume n'est pas forcément qu'un légume
ou une plante aromatique n'est pas que
ça ça veut dire que quoi vous commencez
à travailler au mois d'avril
ça en fait le plan de plantation a été
fait depuis un an parce qu'il nous faut
sélectionner déjà faire des marchés
puisque maintenant on n'a pas trop le
choix faire des marchés sélectionner
des entreprises qui vont nous livrer ces
plantes là c'est un peu des marchés
publics
même pour le vivant
et on a des périodes décalés c'est pas
toujours bien compris par
l'administration et voilà et donc bien
moi j'ai prévu ça il y a un an et avec
l'équipe des jardiniers et et mon ami ça
en culture voilà c'est poussé d'ici
quelques mois on installe ça directement
sur le terrain on va arracher nos
tulipes que l'on peut voir en fleur ici
derrière nous parce que ça c'est
formidable alors là vous faites des
essais c'est ça là en fait on a
reproduit globalement la floraison que
l'on a sur les grands parters que l'on
pourra voir
mais ce qu'il y a étant donné que c'est
l'anniversaire de la naissance de Le
Nôtre je m'étais dit que ce serait
intéressant d'avoir des plantes qui
restituaient un petit peu l'idée des
floraisons que l'on pouvait avoir
voilà on a de la fritillaire impériale
c'est très joli mais on l'oublie
d'accord elle est arrivée bien plus tard
c'est très joli mais voilà
donc à Saint-Germain on a des allées
très blanches très large donc j'ai voulu
quelque chose d'un petit peu sombre
d'autant que vous voyez où il y a des
journées comme ça voilà
ça sort quand même assez bien pour les
couleurs donc on a ici une tulipe un peu
violet et ici on a des tulipes flammées
qui sont intéressantes parce que ça
reprend les tulipes que l'on pouvait
avoir au XVIIe
voilà on en voit voilà très rarement
c'est vrai que ça coûte peut-être un
petit peu plus cher aussi et puis c'est
un petit peu plus compliqué de culture
parfois et donc c'est tulipe ont été
interdites en 1976 parce que on les
obtenait à partir d'un virus qui
attaquait les bulbes et qui faisait
muter les plantes tiens donc les
Hollandais
qui détiennent la majorité des
productions de tulipes on dit stop on
arrête on fixe ça donc ce que l'on
obtient une culture homogène mais ce que
l'on avait je dirais du temps de lonaute
Louis XIV et puis surtout le Grand Condé
à Chantilly qui a des collections
incroyables de tulipe on avait voilà des
tulipes donc viré attaquer par un virus
qui était flammé donc c'est une c'est le
virus qui
se transforme donc on a une tulipe rouge
et elle est attaquée par ce virus donc
elle change de couleur alors on a ce
qu'on appelle ces flammes ça sur le
pétale qui fait apparaître ce jaune ou
il y a l'absence de couleur ce qui est
et
ah oui ça valait très très cher c'est à
dire qu'il y a eu donc tout l'engouement
de la tulipomania et donc une tulipe
pouvait se vendre à l'époque
je dirais le prix de d'un hôtel
particulier place des Vosges
si si et puis des fortunes qui sont
faites et des fortunes qui ont disparu
donc c'est là alors ça c'est voilà c'est
des essais et puis après on va voir ça
sur le terrain il y en a globalement 70
000 tulipes qui sont mises en place
voilà là c'est une petite banquette une
petite plate-bande pour nous nous donner
une idée pour qu'on puisse voir évoluer
les choses mais sur le terrain
ça nous permet aussi d'être plus réactif
grâce à ce genre de choses parce que ça
a été planté un petit peu plus tôt on va
aller voir ça peut-être mais volontiers
alors là où est-ce qu'on arrive dans les
petites terrasses alors voilà c'est ça
on arrive sur la petite terrasse c'était
les anciens jardins de la Dauphine et
donc ça nous permet d'avoir la vue
perspective voilà je trouve que c'est
plus belle des vues que l'on puisse
avoir sur la grande terrasse
on a pas de chance avec le temps
c'est un peu bouché mais sinon en effet
donc la grande terrasse quand on prend
la totalité c'est 2 km 700 voilà et donc
on va jusqu'au Mesnil en direction de
Maisons-Laffitte et surtout ce qui a de
plaisant je trouve pour le pour le
promeneur c'est que on a aux abords une
forêt de 3500 hectares donc la terrasse
est en appui sur le coteau avec 60
mètres de dénivelé au dessus de la Seine
et les 3500 hectares de forêt je trouve
que pour la région parisienne enfin
c'est merveilleux fantastique il a fallu
se battre pour pas avoir ça non oui
voilà parce que en fait Mansart
souhaitait l'incurvé légèrement profiter
davantage de du terrain et le nôtre a
dit non non pour que le on est une œuvre
qui soit intéressante et qui perdure
dans le temps quelque chose de magistral
il faut une ligne droite donc il
explique c'est le seul plan à noter de
Le Nôtre de sa main c'est sans Germain
en lait ou une précise exactement voilà
exactement ce qu'il veut
et donc Colbert ministre des Finances
il a raison c'est vrai c'est quand même
pour le roi
faisons cette ligne droite ça coûtera
plus cher
et donc voilà on a ce résultat de nos
jours qui continue qui entretenu qui
perdure et qui surprend toujours le
visiteur parce que c'est tout un jeu
d'anamorphose c'est-à-dire d'abus de
l'oeil du visiteur faut savoir que le
nôtre a fait César mais dans le cabinet
de peinture de Simon Vouet et donc il
apprend les règles de perspective
perspectives absolument incroyable et il
a pas évidemment ça va très loin aussi
ça allait très loin ça allait très loin
voilà c'était tout le château neuf parce
que Saint-Germain fait c'est un site
compliqué ça l'urbanisme a beaucoup
bouleversé le site mais il y avait un
château qui a été voulu par on va dire
globalement Louis VI le Gros 1200 et
puis le château neuf c'est François 1er
on demande la construction c'est Henri
IV qui en profite il y a des terrasses
qui descendent jusqu'à la Seine c'est le
plus beau des jardins
Renaissance en Europe avec des automates
hydrauliques des jeux d'eau des orgues
d'eau tout ça ça n'existe plus Louis XIV
demande à ce que l'on construise ce
jardin sur le coteau parce que les
terrains et voilà exactement et on crée
deux perspectives Julien il y a un
troisième lieu il faut voir ici quand
même oui c'est ça
là on voit la perspective face au
château Châteauneuf avec le temps
face au château vieux donc l'avenue des
Loges qui perdure toujours on y va très
bien
donc Gilles là on est dans le cette
perspective absolument extraordinaire
donc on a le château derrière c'est ça
les allées de chaque côté il y a un jeu
formidable de couleur non je trouve
enfin entre le château l'allée qui est
blanche et c'est massifs qui sont plutôt
sombres là c'est ça voilà donc on a
voulu en cette année le nôtre faire un
rappel à ce qui pouvait se faire mais
mais il est vrai que sur les banquettes
donc on a on a des couleurs sombres
parce qu'on a une très large aller
blanche donc en contrebas on a ce qu'on
appelle aussi des passe-pieds c'est avec
de la chamotte de la bride concassée qui
rappelle la façade et puis on a les
bahut de de buis taillés qui
maintiennent en hauteur
cette plantation de plantes bisannuelles
on retrouve la tulipe dont on parlait
tout à l'heure la fois remarquer aussi
la taille des arbres c'est vrai qu'on
les voit comme ça on ne fait pas
attention mais c'est ça alors pareil là
c'est ce sont des gabarits d'autres
un mot quand même sur vous on en
reparlera une autre fois mais donc vous
avez une maîtrise histoire de l'art au
départ c'est ça oui
comment bien jardinier après bien moi
cette histoire
c'est parce que ça me plaisait que de
travailler à la fois sur l'histoire le
terrain le végétal de travailler avec
des gens de faire plaisir au public et
de conserver aussi
notre patrimoine et donc bien j'ai fait
la connaissance des jardiniers des du
ministère de la Culture et de la
Communication et j'ai passé les concours
j'ai travaillé où Tuileries et puis
après je suis rentré à Saint-Germain en
tant que jardinier en chef
vous avez les deux passions l'histoire
qui continue parce que exactement on
respecte ce qu'on disait le nôtre les
ces plans et puis et puis on crée aussi
et puis voilà comme par exemple pour cet
été bien on va faire vivre un petit peu
ce patrimoine qui évolue sans cesse
d'accord on reviendra au moment des
installations et puis si vous êtes
toujours d'accord vous évitera parce que
là on n'a pas eu le temps de le faire je
crois qu'il y a des ruches c'est ça
la prochaine fois
je vous en prie